foreign
[Music]
we are live on various electronic
gadgets I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report and it's another Friday
Roundtable Extravaganza for you today on
a Thursday
we can do anything these days joining me
is board certified internist and host of
ask Dr Drew Dr Drew Pinsky and president
of the Brownstone Institute Jeffrey a
Tucker Drew Jeffrey welcome back to the
Reuben report good to be here thank you
so much I love that you become Johnny
Carson
when I walk in you know this is our our
new garage Studio here and when I walk
in from my actual house when I open up
the door I play The Tonight Show theme
song so the guys can give me a round of
applause and you know I've got an
alcoholic like Ed McMahon over here it's
very impressive
uh all right I'm glad to have you guys
on I thought right before we started
that you guys had been on together I've
wanted to have the two of you together
but apparently not but Jeffrey you do go
on on Drew's Show often so we're going
to talk some covid stuff we're going to
talk some economy stuff and uh oh and
then we lost an F-35 plane for a couple
days so a whole bunch for you before we
get to it let me tell you guys about TWC
Health uh guys I want to introduce you
to the guys at wellness company and
specifically their medical emergency kit
awake doctors like Dr Peter McCullough
started the wellness company to build a
parallel Health Care system and bring
about change in a corrupt and failing
system part of that is to is helping you
to take control of your health and
supporting you through whatever the next
thing is that gets thrown our way most
people don't trust health care right now
in fact over 40 percent of Americans say
they would avoid a doctor or a hospital
unless it was a catastrophic situation
man Drew I have you on for the right Ed
that's where the wellness company
yeah oh good good good the wellness
company's medical emergency kit comes in
eight potentially life-saving
medications for you to keep on hand in
times of need natural disasters supply
chain shortages medical emergencies Etc
rest easy knowing that you have
emergency antibiotics antivirals and
anti-parasitics to help keep you and
your family safe the kit includes a
comprehensive guidebook so you never
have to guess how much to take or when
to take it if you're like me and you
want to make sure your family is
prepared for the unexpected go to TWC
DOT health slash Reuben use code Reuben
for 15 off at checkout that's TWC health
dot com slash wait that's TWC DOT health
slash Reuben code Reuben for 15 off and
now back to me Drew you want to chime in
on that because I didn't even realize
that was our ad for today and it fits
I'm an advocate for TWC I work with them
but this kit particularly it's exact I
mean almost precisely I don't know why
this hasn't been done sooner what I
think people need for travel amongst
other things if you travel it's a
perfect kid and it's got a guidebook and
you meet with a doctor to talk about it
it's just exact I just this is the
future of healthcare frankly so here we
go well there you go guys you don't need
my endorsement get it straight from Dr
Drew all right before we jump into the
show Jeffrey every time you are on this
show for the rest of the eternity I will
always give you credit as the guy more
than anybody else that was in my circle
that you were against lockdowns you were
against all of the craziness two weeks
to stop the spread all of it from day
one and that kind of sets us up for the
first story today because some info came
out about fauci's finances the other day
we've got a quote from The Daily Mail a
Freedom of Information Act requests
filed at the end of his tenure revealed
fauci and his wife Dr Christine Grady
had a net worth that exceeded 11 million
in 2022 up from
7.6 million in 2019 so you can see he
got a nice bump during the covid years
he also was the highest paid employee in
the federal government about 400 Grand a
year Jeffrey I will start with you I
know you don't love the policies of
fauci but what do you make of a guy like
him basically getting super rich and and
you know half of his wealth basically
came in these last three years one
wonders if this has any relationship to
why he changed his mind about lockdowns
and even about vaccines uh in February
so you know he was against lockdowns he
thought that covert was going to be just
a kind of a serious flu probably
he wrote The Watch and post at the time
a letter that said we don't need
vaccines to get out of this pandemic
it's going to go away on its own and
then uh come you know about February
26th or something like that he flipped
in the other direction why exactly that
happened uh I I I don't know but I've
always assumed had something to do with
the Wuhan lab again of functional
research and the possibility that NIH
was itself
responsible to some extent and just you
know for the for a lab League that might
have led to the pathogen and uh he was
led to panic but I I cannot fill in the
details this is a lot of what my own
research team is doing all the time is
trying to figure this out but there's a
lot of money sloshing around you know
the fact that he ends on the other side
of this much richer than he was before
we don't have Clarity really on the
relationship between his personal
finances and other NIH employees and
royalties from vaccine companies for
example it's very difficult to get that
information it takes you know a lot of
Investigation there's just a lot more to
know oh and I would like to know Drew
I'm not saying actually that there's
anything nefarious here but the Optics
on this kind of thing where the guy goes
from Seven mil again as a as a
government employee you know a humble
everyone said he was a humble government
employee
it gets to about 12 million now like
just Optics wise and I know you have a
you have a bit of a is it fair to say
complex relationship with this yes yes
yes complexity because you know he I was
a deep admirer since the AIDS pandemic
it's actually why I got involved in
radio was he when I was a young
physician working on A's patients hand
over fist he was out there saying you
got to get out and educate it's
interesting a lot of his fear uh
techniques were precisely what he
applied in the covet pandemic just
wasn't appropriate at all we we actually
uh congratulated ourselves for scaring
an entire generation of high school and
college students that they were going to
get AIDS and they didn't and we
congratulated ourselves uh with covet it
ended up being a catastrophe but I
actually when I saw 11 million I was
actually relieved because the rumors I
was hearing about his participation and
possibly in some of these some of these
extraordinary uh changed ordinary sums
of money that were flying around during
covet I I now needs to be explained why
I went from seven to twelve that's the
bad Optics here I mean but if he's you
know saved his his and his wife's salary
over many many he's 80 something years
old I mean it's possible he makes up to
save seven million dollars that's
possible but this sudden bump is what
needs to be explained we need to see
what's going on in there but again there
were lots of more serious allegations
flying around so for me it was a little
bit of a relief right and by the way hit
the amount of money he he's made in this
is kind of insignificant to I would
argue a lot of the confusions that he
pushed on the American people and he's
still out there even though he's out of
the job right now he's still out there
on TV every single day every big news
show saying things that I think are
actually very confusing if not outright
lies let's show you one from the last
day or so again we have experience with
this type of vaccine in billions of
people it's a safe vaccine of course
with the MRNA there's a very very very
low risk particularly in young men of
getting a myocarditis but if you look at
the risk of myocarditis from covet
itself is greater than the risk of the
vaccine
Drew I asked you right before we started
the show because I wanted to make sure I
was getting it right I could not find
anything that said that that what he
just said there is true that the risk of
getting myocarditis from covid and young
men is higher than if you were to be
back so we couldn't find that and and
just on a personal note I know a guy
who's in his early 20s College age uh
who has myocarditis now who had no
health problems before coven right and
he was forced to get backs to go to
college so can you hit this one so this
is the complexity of this situation what
fauci is reporting a study that was did
show a little higher in sense of
myocarditis from covet across all ages
and myocarditis from covid is in terms
of persistent myocarditis very rare in
young people and older people there
often is a component of myocarditis that
resolves when the covet goes away the
problem here is exactly what Dave you're
pointing out you're taking a healthy
person forcing them to put something in
their body and making them sick and Co
and fauci said something accurate it's a
Rel it's a safe vaccine for the most
part rare risk of myocarditis true even
rarer risk of severe covet in that age
group so the risk reward this is the
part they have left out since the
beginning of covet which is that the
risk of covet is nil the risk of
myocarditis is somewhat above nil
therefore the risk reward doesn't really
balance out especially if you're going
to mandate and this is at the core of
what Aaron carriati has been saying a
psychiatrist who was was drummed out of
his position as the head of bioethics
for raising this very issue you don't
have justification for mandates given
the actual risk reward by the way I
think he was also kicked off YouTube he
is on Rumble just uh just FYI uh Jeffrey
when when you hear fauci on the news now
do you think everyone will fall for it
all over again you know it seemed like a
few weeks ago at the at the beginning of
September they were really on this push
to kind of bring covid back Dr Jill
Biden got it Whoopi got it like schools
are starting you better watch out it
seems like it didn't quite take but I'm
always looking for that moment where
suddenly they're like okay new variant
let's roll and you know that a whole
bunch of people are just gonna fall for
it all over again yeah a lot of people
will but but there's a passionate
minority that will not and they're very
well informed they're super active
they're very attentive to the news I
don't know how what percentage of the
population is is it 20 25 that are just
going to say no lockdowns no more
boosters we're gonna know more by the
way after the we get the data on the
uptake of the new uh the new vaccine
that just came out isn't it that isn't
that though incredible that even now
they're on TV pushing new vaccines I
think I think it was Kathy hokel in New
York pushing a new vaccine for six month
olds I mean Drew there's simply no way
they've been I mean first of all I think
it would be criminally insane to be
testing this on six month olds but but
that they get out there and say it again
yeah so there's many layers to that uh
again we've never ever
mandated or actually even recommended a
treatment for a population that haven't
been specifically studied infants
pregnant women now we've got some track
record with this thing we do that's
actually true but we are one of the only
countries in the world to recommend this
vaccine for the under the age of 50. and
most are not recommending for the under
the age of 65 in full disclosure my
elderly patients are fully vaxed and
boosted and have benefited they are
starting to complain though a little bit
lately about side effects of the vaccine
I had not seen that until recently and
even the elderly population have a lot
to be gained again they gain a lot from
the vaccine so the risk reward reverses
for them right and even they have become
somewhat skeptical which really
surprised me I mean I know people beyond
my friend who has myocarditis I know
people that are having balancing issues
I know someone having a vision problem
Drew you mentioned to me I was a covert
or vaccine related weren't you were
having like some cognitive stuff at one
point right I had long I had long covet
and again you have to realize there's
there's vax injury there's long vacs
these people I have several people I
know that have had this long fatigue
syndrome that looks just like long covid
but my experience with long covet is
that it's more likely to resolve within
one to three months the long vax has
been the people I'm seeing have had it
for 18 months 24 months and it really is
disabling and it makes sense because for
some people they seem to be persistently
creating Spike protein and of course
spike is the source of the toxicity We
Believe
Jeffrey as one of the guys that didn't
fall for it and again I will always give
you credit I I should have had you on
every day at the beginning of this thing
uh what would you say to the people that
are on the fence now that really they
still you know they kind of have woken
up a little bit but they just they just
listen to the people that are supposedly
in charge well I find it remarkable but
Dr Drew said is correct I mean after
three and a half years we're still not
getting honesty from the top about the
uh the age gradient of the medically
significant risk from this pathogen
um even aside from even considering wild
type or Delta or Elmer croner this
latest whatever it is it's just not a
risky a pathogen for working a healthy
working age people to say nothing of
children where it's at zero so the
vaccine issue here is very strange
because usually you evaluate drugs on
whether they're safe and effective and
that's important Criterium and this one
the very first question is is it
necessary and for the overwhelming
number of people out there it's just
simply not necessary it doesn't even
pass that test and that's that's always
been the case I mean we knew the age
gradient of risk from this pathogen from
February of 2020 and yet here we are
barely ahead with the vaccine with the
mandates with these Universal
recommendations and uh Biden you know uh
was you know arguing for what 70 80 90 I
think even fouchy at some point that we
wanted 90 of the population vaccinated
why it's just I'm sorry but you're gonna
you're gonna get sick uh you're going to
develop uh your your immune system is
going to scale up to adapt to it that's
how we've got that of every pandemic in
the past this vaccine was never
necessary for for a healthy working age
uh people and I don't know I have to say
oh go ahead I keep asking the question
why I mean what I I keep asking I want
to understand I really try to always
understand both sides of these these
issues and so I'd like some explain to
me why the kids why pushing so hard on
the kids and it's literally no answer
when I have can I give you my theory on
that well my theory is that they're
going for herd immunity which is
something they started with but they're
not going to get there it's just
impossible what's your theory what's
your thoughts go ahead on that point Dr
Drew about herd immunity so that that's
that's conditioned on the idea that the
vaccine stops transmission yeah yeah of
course there's no way you can obtain
herd immunity with a vaccine that
actually doesn't stop in fact correct
and correct and we recognize very early
on that neither was true which is to say
that there is no public health benefit
to these vaccines
if they do not get us to hurt
immediately there might be a private
benefit but they do not make a
contribution to obtaining her correct
correct so that's true yeah my response
would be a little darker I suppose which
is which is that when they realize that
the vaccines weren't quite working the
way that they wanted them to or that
they had planned or whatever they really
started pushing it on kids because they
knew once they had Parents
doing it to their own children the
parent could never turn like you once
you have injected your child with
something that you don't know why you
did it or what it was going to do to
them you sort of have to be in on that
forever because the the the come to
Jesus moment of oh my God I listen to
some government bureaucrat and I did
something that now may have given my kid
a heart problem or or a Litany of other
things I think it just forced more
people to sort of be for it forever
because to confront the reality that you
might have had something to do with
harming your own child is is just so
crazy I don't even think that's much of
a conspiracy theory but speaking of the
people that that sort of lied all the
way this is just like the perfect storm
of stupidity Lori Lightfoot who was of
course was the basically communist mayor
of Chicago and destroyed that City what
happens uh when you're a communist
politician you get fired or kicked out
and then you end up at Harvard that's
where she's lecturing now and check this
out from the Chicago Sun Times former
Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot is a fish a
college lecturer at least for a semester
as her graduate level class on health
policy and Leadership
at Harvard University got underway last
two weeks stay tuned guys Lightfoot said
she will use use a mock press conference
a simulated community meeting and guest
speakers to teach in part about the
dangers of politicizing a pandemic and
how to interact with the media drawing
on lessons learned from running a city
amid covid-19 I just want to get that
right again because we're going to show
you a clip right now she is running a
graduate level class on health policy
and Leadership and now I would like to
show you a little bit of that Health
policy and Leadership Lightfoot style
Chicago middle of covid go
stop playing game
the other the time for educating people
into compliance is over we will shut you
down we will cite you and if we need to
we will arrest you and we will take you
to jail
well I don't think I can say what I'm
thinking because I don't want to get
demonetized today we've been demonetized
twice this week Jeffrey you want to film
this one well she's got a nice College
over there with Jacinda ardern who's
enjoying two fellowships at Harvard so
Harvard's become this sort of sanctuary
for the lockdowns today in Epoch times
ironically I wrote Our column called the
valorization of the tyrants
and it's all about our Dern's
appointment at Harvard with these two
fellowships the Kennedy School of
government and Joel Roth who is the uh
trust and safety uh uh Czar at Twitter
1.0 uh just got hired by the by the
University of Pennsylvania and uh the
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace with the big fancy scholarship so
this is what's happening to all these
and Brian stelter don't forget Brian
stelter is now teaching media at Harvard
I mean you get fired you ruin a country
and just in this case and yeah you get
you end up at these schools yeah so
maybe uh maybe uh Trump's favorite Mario
Cuomo will be next in a full
professorship you know that'll be I you
know it's it's very strange because it's
a small Junta of these of people out
there that engaged in these
unprecedented policies we've never
pursued lockdowns like this business
closures school closures uh Church
closures uh keeping the big box stores
open shutting down all the small
business ruining everybody's lives
inflating the money supplied by a 6.5
trillion dollars and causing rampant
inflation uh worse getting to the point
it's just as bad as it was in 1979.
we've never done anything like this for
you know a basic uh spread of a new
virus nothing like this in in the whole
history of of Modern Life and and and
and we see the results the results are
terrible demoralization loss of
Education loss of health and you know
it's they've obtained the opposite and
yet they're being rewarded for it I mean
Dave it just there's something broken
about the world or something broken
about Academia uh that that this kind of
thing would be happening well that's
actually a great segue can you just
bring us home on this Kobe thing uh in
terms of saying broken as as someone
that has spent you know three four
decades in public life at this point
trying to communicate science to try to
take complex ideas and bring them to
common people uh is your faith just
completely busted not only on on the
covered front but also the the political
front I mean you hear someone like
lightford she had no idea what she was
talking about correct and it's just like
this Confluence of stupidity so yeah so
I have many thoughts one is that was
very familiar for LA County I mean
that's what it felt like in California
too so that was nothing unusual for us
out here in the west yes I left you were
at my goodbye dinner yeah because of
that and and by the way let's be fair
she's saying it'll involve Lessons
Learned I'm dying to know what lessons
she learned I really want to know what
did she learn during this because my
suspicion is nothing because there's an
irrational certainty that has gripped
people that have no understanding of the
topic of health and particularly
infectious diseases it's exactly when
they close the schools here in Los
Angeles I was on a nightly program here
in uh Channel 11. and the school board
came in and said we're closing the
schools I said who told what doctor what
what what professional who works in this
area who has some degree of judgment
with this told you to do that no one we
think it's the right thing to do we're
certain it's the right thing to do in my
world we have rational uncertainty we're
trying to arrive at an approximation of
the truth irrational certainty lays to
untoward harm and that harm is always
perpetrated by people who have no
knowledge in a subject matter they are
bureaucrats and have no Health
experience whatsoever and are making
risk reward judgments really they're not
making risk or judgments right they are
making these bizarre sweeping Fiats that
have profound adverse effect without
understanding what they are doing and
this irrational certainty is the thing
that has gripped us now as far as health
communication goes that's one of the
things I was gobsmacked by during the
pandemic because we learned during HIV
and AIDS how to change Behavior it was
through narrative and through delivering
stories about people like the people you
want to change the behavior of using
humor and music and letting people see
the consequences of choices we there was
a discipline and for years involved in
changing health behavior all of that was
tossed out the window in the name of
authoritarian
authoritarian kinds of weird
centralization of decision making that
was like nothing in human history you
guys Jeffrey said in modern history I
would pause it in human history period
yeah that's probably correct you know
there are other features of this thing
we still don't understand how did it
happen that all the hospitals at the
same time all over the country shut down
to everything except uh emergency
surgeries and covet I mean how did that
happen so you know all the cancer
screens have gone and we're seeing a
huge increase in cancer uh partially as
a result of that but elective surgeries
that were gone the hospitals were
starved of Revenue we got dancing nurses
and nothing how did who made that
decision uh I asked an expert about this
about the hospital protocol which were
very often deadly during this period you
know who made this decision they just
decisions to shut all the hospitals in
the whole country whether covet was
there or not to shut them all down for
everything but covert and we do you know
that we still don't have an answer to
who precisely made that decision it's so
strange and and the division of the
workforce between essential and
unessential you know just one day it was
it was March 18th uh 2020. this
organization called sisa cyber
infrastructure security infrastructure I
don't know agency uh
lots of the Department of Labor but sisa
sent out a PDF and you had to read the
PDF to find out if you were essential or
not they split the workforce right down
the middle and and created this kind of
weird techy feudalism uh just by by
executive Fiat I mean who gave Sis to
that Authority and then to say to people
putting aside the Ridiculousness of it I
mean to say to a certain set of people
you are unessential to the operation of
this world and this economy and America
you are actually unessential but
speaking of unessential people Janet
Yellen let's move on to the economy uh
Janet Yellen uh is telling us that the
economy I think is kind of doing all
right it's a little unclear take a look
we still have a good healthy labor
market consumer spending remains quite
robust we've seen strong industrial
production
um I don't see any signs that uh the
economy is it the downturn and this is
the best of all worlds Jeffrey I'm kind
of a two minds on this one because you
know first on a ground like just my life
like I'm here in Florida south Florida
especially but Florida is just
flourishing so many people are moving
here there's construction everywhere
we're building roads infrastructure new
businesses like so I get that that's a
very micro version of this on the other
hand is she saying there's no signs of a
problem but interest rates if you were
trying to buy a house right now you're
basically paying about nine percent
wouldn't that in alone be some indicator
of a bit of a problem uh well yeah that
that's right but you know everything she
said is false the labor markets are not
healthy and you're right about Florida
right Florida and Texas seem to be you
know among all the states be doing
pretty well but you know I'm I'm over
here in the Northeast I can tell you
it's not looking so good but even if you
look at the data on let's just consider
labor for example
um she says old labor markets are fine
she's talking about the unemployment
rate you know which has no relevance
whatsoever these times labor market
participation has still not recovered
from the pandemic and I'm starting to
get a really incredulous about the bls's
labor releases the last one was claiming
all these glorious job creation when I
looked at the numbers and they said that
part-time jobs for economic reasons were
unchanged when I went and looked at the
actual tables that they published it
said the opposite there was a 5.4
percent increase in part-time jobs for
for economic reasons and a reduction of
full-time jobs I'm looking at this
thinking okay so people are losing
full-time jobs and picking up part-time
jobs even though they want a full-time
job and they can't get it and that's up
5.4 percent in one month and you call
that a healthy labor market this is not
a healthy labor market
uh Drew to connect this uh go ahead and
yeah and everything else everything else
she said is completely wrong and of
course they never want to talk about
inflation which by the way is coming
back again contrary to my predictions I
thought it would be down to three
percent by now no it's a 3.4 and
actually if you annualize last month's
increase in inflation it comes to 7.8
percent and in Energy Services we're in
double digits 10.4 so it's it's
re-accelerating right so isn't that the
part true that I think most people can
see where so the average person
obviously isn't going to dive into the
economic charts the way Jeffrey is but
the average person can see when you go
to the store things do seem to be more
expensive and your dollar is not going
as far like isn't that really kind of
the simplest way to look at this 100 I
mean that's a great model for looking at
everything other than what the
centralized authorities are telling you
are you going to believe me you're
you're lying eyes what do you see around
you what do you feel it's overwhelming
it's talked about constantly go to a
restaurant and see if you don't feel it
immediately when the check comes it is
everywhere and everyone is aware and it
feels I have no other again I'm not an
economist but it feels rickety it feels
like it could all of a sudden topple and
the people that are suffering the most
of course are young people trying to get
their lives going they look at in
California
unless you're a homeless person you are
you are a piggy bank for the state
that's it and it's it's unfortunate it's
just it's it's atrocious yeah I feel
terrible for people they're getting
their lives going out here
Let's uh let's throw to one more let me
throw to one more clip of uh Johnny
Yellen because interestingly she's
talking about so she's sort of saying
the reverse of what we're saying about
that there is a disc well it's not quite
the reverse but she's basically saying
there's a disconnect but what she with
what she claims the reality is Jeffrey
doesn't agree with that versus what the
public perception is
I'm not asking you to play therapists
with the American voter but there seems
to be a disconnect between the numbers
we're seeing and the way people are
feeling about the economy and how do you
account for it I I agree with you that
there's a disconnect and
um I don't have a simple and convincing
answer but Americans have been through a
lot the pandemic really took a toll on
American families on children on
households we are enjoying a remarkable
recovery but
um also with high inflation much of it
reflecting Supply bottlenecks that
developed during the pandemic and then
with Russia's brutal attack on Ukraine
we saw a surge in gas prices in food
prices
Americans have been reeling from high
inflation they do realize in polls that
it's coming down and and Americans
financial situation actually improved
during the pandemic
Drew thank you for that Collective drone
I think I think that was huge Jeffrey
the way though that she combines all of
these things right so and like I was
just shocked it didn't get to climate
change also right like of course that'll
be that we probably cut the clip too
early but this combination of things
that sort of have nothing to do with
each other but are the talking points of
the day she did it very seamlessly there
yeah she's very clever well you know
when she's referred to the pandemic was
devastated the pandemic response yes
that's exactly my take
what we did is what we did in response
to the pandemic that destroyed everybody
the virus didn't call it caused this and
did you catch how she's blaming Supply
chains for the inflation they never want
to talk about the Federal Reserve you
know which which Unleashed you know
helicopter money worth 6.5 trillion
dollars you know we've never seen at the
height it was something like 27
annualized increase uh just uh yeah just
incredible and as for Americans doing
better yes we got stimulus payments do
you know the value of those stimulus
payments is now gone in light of all the
inflation
the dollar is lost between 16 and 20
cents from its 2019 uh uh uh value and
so the stimulus payments are gone it was
the greatest head fake in the history of
Economics I mean it's like look you're
rich you're rich oh thanks this is
wonderful and and then they just took it
all the way uh through inflation as for
uh the Americans being better off right
now she's completely neglecting a very
interesting survey that comes from the
Census Bureau now I trust this one
because this is where the Census Bureau
is actually asking people how much money
do are you making this year and the the
survey comes out every year it's not
from the BLS it's not from uh an agency
that the Bible Administration has now
gotten clever at controlling it's from
the Census Bureau so I tend to trust it
comes out once a year it just came out
American median household income is down
for the third year in a row in real
terms so what she said is absolutely
wrong and let me just finish on this one
of the she says there's no risk of a
downturn well you know what there was
never an upturn and and I've argued this
at length in many many places I don't
think we ever left the recession of
March 2020. then everything else is an
illusion right so it's funny because
she's kind of saying it's an Optics
problem and in a weird way you're saying
well yeah you guys have lied about
everything so there's a grand Optics
problem maybe not the one she's talking
about uh this idea though Drew of
stimulus where they give us back money
isn't that sort of the problem in the
first place like why is it that nobody
is ever like oh oh how about we take
less of your money in the first place
you figure out what to do with your own
money instead of us just giving you
crumbs back that we took from you people
don't seem to put that together yes this
is the part that nobody can understand
is that they I I remember I it reminds
me of when I was interviewing one of the
heads of the the budget director uh the
chairman of the budget director budget
committee here in California and she was
talking about these you know shortfalls
and and I said yeah what are you going
to do she goes we don't have the money
and so I guess yeah so what she goes
well you know the federal government
needs to just give us I was like what
where do you where did the head of the
budget committee where do you think
money comes from I I'm also thinking
about you know the richest man of the
mayor in the world and the history of
humanity was a Molly King named Mansa
Musa and he went on a grand European
tour this is like thousands of years ago
and he had so much gold he handed out
wherever he went and by doing that he
crashed the economy of everybody he
visited and he had to go back in and buy
the gold back to stabilize their
economies on his way home it's a perfect
uh example of what they're doing all
over the place yesterday we showed a
clip of Eric Adams in New York City who
made New York a sanctuary City and now
he's upset as to what happens when you
just allow 10 000 people a month in and
his answer was well we don't have the
money anymore we put 2 billion towards
it we need more money from the federal
government and it's like guys the
federal government let all these people
in in the first place it just never ends
but sorry let's finish up with the
ridiculous story of the week because the
government which clearly none of us are
loving these days it also lost an F-35
for a couple days in South Carolina this
is absolutely wild from the hill the U.S
military is hunting for an 80 million
dollar F-35 fighter jet after a pilot
ejected from the military aircraft near
Charleston South Carolina on Sunday
officials at Joint Base Charleston said
they were working with a local Marine
base to locate an F-35 that was involved
in a mishap Sunday afternoon the pilot
ejected safely from the Jet and is
receiving medical care if you have any
information that may help our recovery
teams locate the F-35 please call the
base defense operations and blah they
wrote on Twitter and ladies and
gentlemen in case you haven't seen it
somebody did find the jet fear not I
love this guy this is Randolph white in
South Carolina this guy should is a
national hero as far as I'm concerned
normally it's pretty quiet but on Sunday
afternoon I was in
I was in them taking a shave
and I heard us
oh I said what in the wall of this and I
heard boom in my whole house show white
says he didn't realize it was a plane at
the time so he didn't call anybody
come out of space or something
and I said well there's a airplane it
needed to be reported let the thing
would fly I swear to God I would rather
have that guy in charge of whatever the
high hell is going on here the Lori
Lightfoot or Anthony fauci or Janet
Yellen
I'm gonna go down and have lunch with
him Drew isn't his story just isn't it
just perfect like they literally lost an
F-35 and they asked people to call them
if they found it like
yeah it's a brilliant example of
government incompetence but you know H.L
menkin said thank goodness we don't get
all the government we pay for it you
know so yeah that's me
but I I got to say something I you know
Pilots I talk to keep saying the same
thing which is a a aircraft that is
still flying you don't eject from and so
this mishap that's such a carefully
chosen word they will they will Glide
the plane they will do all kinds of
things with the plane to kind of get it
towards something like a landing or a
safety or unless it's rapidly changing
altitude which they did not say that
they did not say a mechanical error they
did not say a major malfunction they
said some sort of mishap and that is a
bizarre choice of words it's a bizarre
response they couldn't track an F-35 and
where it was going did it was it hacked
was it taken over did the pilot do
something egregious I mean there's
there's lots of possibilities here other
than something routine right well the
major mechanical malfunction they did
not say that and the plane did not lose
altitude before the the pilot took out
to be clear drew the pilot is now
blaming this on bad weather it still
doesn't explain why they lost the plane
after 35 can't fly through bad weather
if that's true I want my 85 million
dollars back yeah exactly true it's made
by the government I mean come on but
watch this is just perfect this is
perfect government 101 here is uh John
Kirby uh who has become sort of the most
you know Corinne Jean-Pierre is like the
obvious clown of the administration but
he is running a really tight second
right now and just making up nonsense
watch this let me ask you about the F-35
how does the U.S military lose a 100
million dollar plane that will be
something that they will investigate the
believe me after every Aviation mishap
the Pentagon does what the Pentagon does
they'll investigate it to try to get the
answers on what happened
um and they'll also I'm sure look at
their own search and Recovery efforts of
the aircraft itself to see whether that
was conducted uh in uh in all the
appropriate ways they'll they'll
investigate this and as the defense
department always does they'll be
transparent about it when they when they
find the answer oh well they'll be
transparent I mean this is the gov
like if my guys lost a piece of
equipment a camera if a camera was
missing from my studio all hell would be
breaking loose until it would be found
okay and it's like Jeffrey
it's just perfect he's perfect right
he's a perfect bureaucrat right now he's
perfect you know and I've never been a
big fan of government uh I've never been
hugely trusting of government but these
days uh it's a different level you know
I just assume that anything coming out
of these people's mouths is is just is
completely uh you know made up to to
cover up and the idea of the Department
of Defense being transparent you know
the Department of Defense was involved
very deeply in the coveted response we
still cannot get a fix on that I would
love to see some transparency there
mishap though boy that word is soaked
that's their talking point that's the
word they keep repeating there's
something embedded in that word mishap
guys it was a pleasure as always I hope
you but well I was gonna say I hope you
both get home but yeah I think you both
are at home without losing your car or
your plane or your helicopter or
anything else uh we'll link to all your
stuff down below for everybody else
we've got a post game show coming up in
about 30 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com and we've got a
cold close can we call this AI would
this be considered AI this might be AI
related I don't want to be sued uh
thanks guys we'll see you
I'm not exactly sure what you mean oh
[Music]
retainer
you want us to give you cash right now
[Music]